a two-hour Drive West along the coast
from the earthquake zone the big Port of
Merson was the first stop for many
people fleeing the disaster in southern
turkey Madison is very different from
other cities because it's the closest
safe City to the disaster area in the
first days it was quite frightening we
saw people all around the city with
nowhere to go with their bags and with
their pajamas on
is an academic and Community organizer
who has been helping the influx of
newcomers with Aid packages
at centers and dormitories throughout
the city people are in temporary
accommodation with most saying they want
to go back to their provinces despite
their ordeal
if our houses are rebuilt we'll
definitely go back we can't give up on
our hometown it's estimated that 2
million population of this city has
suddenly grown by around a quarter
the city of Merson is suffering from
this but after the tent and container
cities are completed in the earthquake
zone I believe that the people will
return to their hometowns but some
Reports say rents have more than doubled
making it harder for existing residents
to get homes and more demands are being
put on schools and hospitals as many
people it seems are choosing to stay as
a major Hub Merson has experienced
influxes of newcomers over time but
there are concerns about how it will
cope with this latest surge most of them
won't go back I mean this is not the
it's not the first time that the city
imagine experience this this city is a
Mediterranean City very calm very pretty
and there are a lot of chances of of
economic survival when you don't have
resources to share there will be
conflicts there will be very struggles
among the peoples the problems facing
mercen it seems likely to be faced
nationally
it's reckoned several million people who
lost their livelihoods and homes in the
disaster have left the earthquake
affected area for new lives throughout
turkey even after the recovery it's
questionable just how many of them will
ever go back Rob McBride Al Jazeera
Mason turkia